programme de contrôle confirmé dans un récent
balayage sonar du fond de l'océan, les scientifiques ont
enregistré un son jamais entendu auparavant par
les oreilles humaines à partir de films d'animation et de
nickelodéon primordiaux pour sauver leur
surface du monde d'accord, tous les
personnages secondaires viennent avec moi, ils doivent venir
chez nous
s'il vous plaît bébé ce gars  sait qu'il a l'air
intelligent il va acheter cette
barbe à papa si vous mangez tout ce que vous
auriez assez d'énergie pour courir
pourquoi le sucre va-t-il s'estomper en
2015 cela arrive quand je suis
nerveux  devenir des super-héros
piscine sportive
Patrick parle-moi Betty je vois une
lumière brillante c'est beaucoup
merci c'est le film de Bob l'éponge une éponge hors
de l'eau à nouveau la justice 3d est mieux servie
peut-être que nous aurions dû choisir une meilleure
superpuissance pour toi Patrick